so i i i had ordered a new pc build like
i
bought everything i got joey to buy the
exact same one yeah because i needed an
upgrade too
and so we ordered the the the 380
graphics card which is the video i don't
know if you're familiar with that
yes yes now i am oh believe me chat made
sure i know so we ordered it and it got
delayed so when i was building joey's
new pc films he didn't know how to build
it yeah dude
to preface joey has like the most jank
setup you'd expect to ever expect for
like a professional youtuber
he he [ __ ] streams and edits on one
screen
one screen oh man how did
you know what i mean that's how i feel
when i have one he's a professional in
all senses of like i've been doing this
for almost eight years now and i've been
doing it all
and i'm like how did you read the
comments it's like oh i just popped it
out do you have do you have two months
is my friend did you have three monitors
i have four
that's true come on come on
i was building joey's new pc and and
obviously the 380 hadn't arrived yet so
i said don't worry joe we'll just take
the old one out of your pc
yeah right right because i had a 980 in
my old yeah and you know when you
have a new graphics card they have like
little rubber pieces in the hdmi and the
display port yeah they were still in
on joey's thing and i thought oh did you
put them back in joey
he was like no and i'm like did you ever
take these out and he was like no i
never took them out
so joey joey for five years
used a 980 graphics card that was
plugged in powered
but it was still yeah but you used to
still use the intel cpu graphics
plug this one hdmi monitor into his
[ __ ] motherboard
oh my god he's a professional youtuber
so basically so basically when we pulled
out this like dusty oh
so dusty
who's never been used for five years
geez so basically it was the dustiest
brand new 980 that i've
that you'll ever see oh my god i have no
idea how he didn't have problems with
like streaming or ad editing videos yeah
yeah it's pretty nice that's what you
get for like just playing
just playing how to make it honestly
dude like a i only play retro games
and b i'm a console player right so like
i've never had to deal with like
graphics card or any of that kind of
[ __ ] but i guess now i do
so so no it doesn't matter how bad you
are
jerry for five years had a graphics card
that he did not use i never used it
and this is this isn't like joey built
it it's pretty built
yeah but that's the problem right was
hey because like every computer i've
used up on like my entire life because
my dad worked in it for
like [ __ ] 30 years right he just
stopped
he never taught me any of this [ __ ] oh
my god
he would just set this [ __ ] up for me
because i remember like i remember like
when i was the boomer grandma
i was just like i'm literally one step
away from like how does email work
i get that so like yeah so like because
i never like
i i never pc game like my entire life
like i've always been console only like
ever since i was a kid and only recently
i started pc gaming right
because yeah yeah because of like you
know all my friends and whatnot so and
especially
like when streaming came into the image
because like i couldn't stream in
australia right like my upload speed
get do you know that's what i've heard
yeah do you know how you know you know
what my upload speed was
tell me point four come on man that
can't be you're real oh meg
you can't stream on there i couldn't
like an nes emulator and it was still
lagging
what yeah i couldn't stream right so of
course
because i had this garbage computer with
this garbage internet yeah pc gaming was
just completely out of the option
and so when i moved here and i was like
oh my god i can actually
stream it's like coming back to the 21st
century yeah it was like oh my god
upload speeds that are more than a
megabyte holy [ __ ]
and then yeah i just never used my
graphics card basically i was an
absolute clown about it
and uh these two will never let me
forget about it there's something kind
of beautiful about that i feel i feel
good about myself now thank you for that
confidence